Peggy's 16
welcome to battlefleet gothic armada new
RTS video game adaptation of games
workshop's classic tabletop game pitting
the Imperium chaos orcs and Eldar
against each other and visceral space
back the ships of battlefleet gothic are
miles long the larger battleships are
weighty and perilous fight in
multiplayer flanking the enemy carefully
aligning your part with that of the
target to launch a salvo of torpedoes or
to violently ram them or sliding close
to expose your broadside cannons and
unleash a barrage of heavy fire every
action is weight in inertia mistakes
will rarely be left unpunished by your
opponent's maneuvering and positioning
in bousley gothic is one of the many
keys to success made in unreal for
battlefleet gothic Armada offers
management of every ship composing your
fleet both during in between battles
with different skills and abilities
customize all aspects of your ship
whether its crew for weaponry or repairs
or new skills such as the augur probe
mission site or micro warp jump you'll
be able to add more as each ship games
levels each faction also has access to
four different favours granting both
passive and active abilities also
changing the appearance of the ships
marking their elite status mixing all of
these options allow
player to grunt each ship specific role
enabling commanders to build fleets to
match their playstyle and perfectly
counter the enemy hone multiple play
styles to manage battlefleet gothic
armadas darius game mode convoy escorts
space station assault breakthrough data
recovery assassinates and even the
classic planetary assault you'll have to
select ships the best fit the bill the
campaign in battlefleet gothic Armada
takes places you protect the sector from
the 12th Black Crusade of Abaddon the
Despoiler systems in the Gothic sector
will be repeatedly attacked by Abaddon
splits as well as the brutal orcs and
enigmatic elder defend them for unique
bonuses and watches the story branch is
depending on your choices
battlefleet gothic is coming to BC at
the end of March
[Music]